[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello,
everybody.
Thank you for joining
us here today.
We have two engineers from NuoDB
who are going to share
their elastic, scalable SQL
database built for the cloud
and how it runs on Google
Compute Engine.
So to quickly introduce myself,
I'm Brian Dorsey.
I'm a developer engineer on
Google Compute Engine.
SETH PROCTOR: I'm
Seth Proctor.
I'm the core engineer and
architect on NuoDB.
TOMMY REILLY: And my name is
Tommy Reilly, and I'm also an
engineer on the NuoDB product.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
Thank you for coming
out, guys.
SETH PROCTOR: Thanks
for having us here.
BRIAN DORSEY: I think
we're going to
jump straight to demo.
SETH PROCTOR: Sweet.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh,
no, we're not.
We're going to jump
straight to NuoDB.
What is NuoDB?
SETH PROCTOR: NuoDB is a brand
new relational database that
is designed to be cloud scale.
And I think most people know
what we mean when we say it's
a relational database.
It's something that is ACID.
It's something that
speaks SQL.
It has JDBC and ODBC drivers.
It works with the standard
ecosystem of tools that you
expect to see out there.
It's the cloud-scale part,
obviously, that's interesting
and exciting.
And that's why we're
here today.
And cloud scale can mean many
different things to many
different people.
We're going to show a couple
specific pieces of that today.
And what we're really going
to show is that we are a
relational database that can
scale out the way people want
to scale out infrastructure.
So you can start developing on a
laptop, and as you need more
resources, you can add
a few more machines.
And then obviously, as you need
more resources, you can
do something like take it Google
Compute Engine and
really scale massively.
And it's designed to do all the
other things you want in a
cloud-scale environment, in
terms of security, in terms of
resource management, in terms of
ease of use, multi-tenancy,
all kinds of other great
features that you really want
in a cloud.
BRIAN DORSEY: And to be clear,
it's a real SQL database.
SETH PROCTOR: It's a
real SQL database.
And we'll talk about that later,
but yeah, it's a true
SQL database.
But it really scales the way
no SQL-- or sharded systems
work, but with no sharding,
no partitioning.
Very easy to work with.
We're pretty excited about it.
We think it's pretty cool.
TOMMY REILLY: 100% ACID.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
Well, let's see what
that looks like.
TOMMY REILLY: All right.
Let's see what this
looks like.
First, Seth is going to unlock
the screen for us.
Thank you, Seth.
And you should be looking at
the YCSB demonstrator that
we've created.
CDMS is a term that we've
come up with.
Apologize if the font's a little
small, but you'll be
able to see the graph, I think,
which is the big thing.
So I'm going to kick
off this demo.
And then I'll talk about
what's going
on while it's running.
But this is the Yahoo!
Cloud Serving Benchmark.
And what it is, is--
waiting for it to get running
here, make sure it comes up.
And hit Start.
Seem to be having some
technical issues.
Bear with me for a second.
SETH PROCTOR: So basically, what
we're looking at here is
we took the standard YCSB
benchmark that's used to
demonstrate common web-scale
applications.
And we've wrapped kind of
a nice UI around it to
demonstrate how you can start
with a single machine, and you
can start adding more resources
as you need
them to scale out.
BRIAN DORSEY: So this is a
visualization on top of the
existing benchmark.
SETH PROCTOR: That's right.
That's exactly right.
So this is exactly just the
standard YCSB benchmark.
We haven't done anything
to it.
We haven't done any of the fun
tricks to make it work
particularly well for us
by tweaking something.
We just took the vanilla
benchmark.
But what we're doing is we're
starting with a cold
environment.
And that's why Tommy's tweaking
something right now
is we're starting with
a cold environment.
And we're bringing things
online, and we're bringing
them online in the Google
environment.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got you.
So when you're evaluating
infrastructure to run NuoDB
on, what kind of
infrastructure do you look for?
What makes NuoDB run
really well?
SETH PROCTOR: That's
a great question.
So I said earlier that NuoDB is
a product that's designed
to be cloud scale, right?
And so part of that means that
you have to understand that
failures happen in a cloud.
You have to understand that
systems go down unexpectedly.
Networks fail unexpectedly.
Even when things are up
and available, you get
inconsistent network spikes,
dips, and you get all kinds of
weird, crazy things happening
in clouds
that you don't expect.
And so being cloud scale
isn't just about being
able to scale out.
It's about being resilient to
those failures and, when
possible, try to stay
ahead of them.
So in theory, we are designed
to work with any kind of
commodity hardware, any kind
of commodity networks.
We're very good at working
with unpredictable
environments.
But anything that has better
network capabilities, has
smoother network capabilities,
has higher CPU, is obviously
going to let any piece of
software run better.
And so that's part of what
really appealed to us about
our experience in Google was an
environment that really was
a solid networked environment,
solid set of virtual machines.
How are we doing, Tommy?
TOMMY REILLY: I think we're
having some issues connecting.
For some reason, my Linux
laptop can't talk to the
Google infrastructure.
But I think I may have
it reset, so we're
going to try again.
BRIAN DORSEY: We're
good to go.
SETH PROCTOR: Excellent.
TOMMY REILLY: I apologize.
SETH PROCTOR: And what
you're see--
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, describe
what we're seeing here.
SETH PROCTOR: Yeah, so what
Tommy's doing here, in part,
part of what you're seeing, the
plus side of getting to
see this kind of working live
is that you're seeing that
he's really right there live
on Google Compute Engine.
He's in there, and he's been
using a number of different
tools as he's trying to figure
out what's going on.
He's using the web interfaces.
He's using the command-line
interfaces.
One of the things that's really
appealed to us about
the Google Compute environment
has been how easy it is to
work with on the command line.
Just the simple utility makes
it really easy to get on to
instances, to provision them,
to set up firewalls, to kind
of monitor what's happening.
It's a really straightforward,
really nicely streamlined way
of just getting running with the
environment and then being
able to run between a Mac
environment, a Linux
environment, a Windows
environment, just get running.
BRIAN DORSEY: Everything
works the same.
SETH PROCTOR: Everything
just works the same.
Yeah.
And it's really easy.
It's really nice to be able to
see everything in one place.
The documentation is just super
streamlined and just
makes it a breeze to
get up and running.
I think from the first time I
sat down and actually started
playing with it to the
time I was running
was just a few minutes.
So that was great.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's
fantastic.
SETH PROCTOR: It works really
well with the NuoDB model we
have, because part of what our
software provides is not just
the database, but it's all
of the management and
provisioning around
the database.
Being a cloud-scale database
means being easy to provision
hosts, easy to get the
software running.
And so it's a really nice match
between the provisioning
and management model in GCE
and the provisioning and
management model that
we have in NuoDB.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
TOMMY REILLY: Seth, that
was a wonderful job of
covering for me.
Thank you.
SETH PROCTOR: Sweet.
TOMMY REILLY: We have
the demo running.
SETH PROCTOR: And we're back.
TOMMY REILLY: We had some
technical issues, but we have
those resolved now.
So we have the demo running
here for you guys to see.
So what I've done is I've
started the YCSB
client on one instance.
We have 32 instances in the
Google Cloud running, but we
start with once.
So the NuoDB database is
provisioned across those.
But right now, I'm just running
one of our database
transaction engines and
one YCSB client.
You can see here with the little
green icon, that's my
GCE instance.
And for this benchmark, which
is the YCSB B workload, it's
5% updates and 95% reads.
We're getting roughly
50,000 to 60,000
transactions a second.
So we have a button here which
will start another transaction
on the next instance and then
also start a client
to hit that, so--
SETH PROCTOR: So just to be
clear, what's happened is--
this is what we were talking
about the managing, right?
Tommy has provisioned a number
of hosts but has only actually
started a database process
running on one of them.
So what he's going to do as this
demo runs, he's going to
start new processes that
will come up cold, will
automatically just start
talking with
the existing processes.
And as that happens, you should
see this graph scale.
TOMMY REILLY: Right.
So if we go back to the graph,
we'll see that with two
instances, we're running, pretty
much very literally,
twice the number of transactions
we were
running with one.
So that's kind of the point
right there with NuoDB.
And there's a lot of databases
that can't just make that one
step from one machine
to two machines.
We made that step relatively
quickly, and
we've shown the scale.
So I'm going to go ahead and
crank it up to four now and
demonstrate some other
things that I'd
like to show you guys.
Interacting with the Google
Compute Engine and the NuoDB
process is very similar.
Google Compute Engine has this
nice command-line tool, nice
little Python tool,
that allows you to
see all your instances.
So here, I've listed all our
instances as 32 instances of
our database.
And I'll show the
web UI as well.
But then, not to be outdone,
NuoDB also has a
command-line tool.
And now here, I'm showing--
hopefully, the font's big
enough, once again--
all of our agents have
provisioned.
Our agents are just management
agents that don't actually run
the database.
But they control starting and
stopping it and monitoring.
And then down below, you'll
see that we have four
transaction engines running on
four different hosts and then
one storage manager that
holds the actual disk.
So that's the command line tool,
and then I'm going to
switch back.
BRIAN DORSEY: And these are the
four instances we should
be seeing the graph
right now, right?
TOMMY REILLY: Yeah, so we're
looking at the graph now, and
you'll see we had step one
was the 60,000 or so.
We went to step two, where
we got up to 120,000.
Now we have four instances,
and we're up to 250,000.
So we'll go ahead and--
SETH PROCTOR: Excellent.
Just keep cranking it up.
TOMMY REILLY: We're going
to crank to eight.
We're developers, so we're big
fans of powers of two.
So we're going to go
to eight next.
And then also--
SETH PROCTOR: To be clear,
there's nothing in our system
that's optimized for
powers of two.
It's just that no matter how the
system is built, we still
can't get away from
talking about--
TOMMY REILLY: Oh, Seth--
SETH PROCTOR: --two,
four, eight.
TOMMY REILLY: Sure, there
are things optimized
for powers of two.
Just not numbers of hosts.
So this is the graphical
administration tool that
allows you to see, and you
get some pretty graphs
about stats and stuff.
But this is one logical
database, as we mentioned
before, and this is going to
show which processes are
involved in serving this
logical database.
Because of font issues,
we can't really scale.
But if I do my little finger
magic here, you should see the
instances I'm running.
And you'll see up here that nine
processes are running.
Again, that's the eight
transaction engines and one
storage manager.
SETH PROCTOR: Right.
And Tommy just said something
really important, which is
that what's really nice about
this model is that there are
all these different
processes running.
They can be running on
different hosts.
They can fail.
They can come up.
They can come down.
But from the point of view of
the developer, from the point
of view of the application,
there's a single logical
database, right?
So there really is one database
we're addressing.
The fact that these processes
are being added, the clients
have no idea about that.
They just know there's
a database
they can address and--
BRIAN DORSEY: So as a developer,
I don't need to
know at all what's going on.
SETH PROCTOR: That's right.
And that means we can bring
things down live.
We can migrate live processes.
We can actually have 100%
availability while we're doing
upgrades or while we're
doing migration.
And still just looks like a
single, live database, which
is really cool.
TOMMY REILLY: So here's a slide
I just want to show
that's going to drive home this
point further about what
we're demonstrating.
This shows kind of
a rough diagram
model of what's running.
So each of these boxes
represents a Google Compute
Engine instance.
So in each box, you'll see a
YCSB client running, there's
an agent running-- which
is NuoDB's agent--
and then a transaction engine.
And then we've done a little
dotted line here to show that
this is one logical
database engine.
So that means that if NuoDB
instance 32 tries to update a
record, and NuoDB instance 1
tries to update a record, only
one of those transactions
is going to proceed.
is These nodes are talking to
each other and making the
semantics of ACID [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN DORSEY: So you need the
network to work well.
TOMMY REILLY: Yes, network
working well helps a lot.
BRIAN DORSEY: Ready
to keep going?
TOMMY REILLY: All right,
so we're right
along nicely with eight.
Should we go to 16?
SETH PROCTOR: Can we jump
straight to 32?
TOMMY REILLY: We
probably could.
We have to wait.
We're starting each transaction
serially, so it'll
take a couple seconds for
all eight to come up.
SETH PROCTOR: You actually can
start as many as you want on
top of each other.
The UI we have here was
designed-- you can see the
Pause, Play buttons.
This was designed as a thing to
help someone step through
and understand what
they're doing.
So the UI itself doesn't
let you do it.
The software lets you do it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got you.
TOMMY REILLY: All right, so
we're almost done starting up
those 16 instances--
the additional eight, sorry.
And you can see that
we're approaching--
SETH PROCTOR: One million.
TOMMY REILLY: One million
TPS, we're approaching.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
TOMMY REILLY: We're not
quite there yet.
All right, so now we have
the engines running.
The numbers are still
updating.
It's fluctuating a little bit.
But in the interest of time,
we will jump right to 32.
SETH PROCTOR: And the important
thing-- so there's
the big curve that we're looking
at, which is that big,
blue curve.
And that's the transactions
per second.
And that's obviously
really exciting.
Down in the lower-left corner,
there's another curve, which
is also pretty cool, which
is showing latency.
And that's showing that even as
we're going from 2 to 4 to
16 to 32 hosts that are
expanding out this database,
we're still hitting
sub-millisecond latency on
these requests.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
SETH PROCTOR: And so it's not
just about that scale out.
We're still very responsive
to all these queries.
And for a lot of people, that's
just as important as
the raw throughput, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
SETH PROCTOR: Oh, Tommy.
Look.
TOMMY REILLY: Yeah, we're
getting there.
We are still in the process
of rolling up these--
bringing online the
additional 16.
BRIAN DORSEY: So if I wanted
to do this, is there
information on how
to get started?
TOMMY REILLY: Yes, so we have
written a blog entry.
And we have a link that we'll
show at the end here.
But on nuodb.com, we have a tech
blog, and we wrote a blog
entry describing the nuts and
bolts of what we went through
and how we did it.
And we hope to be publishing
some assets from that to make
available to developers.
And definitely recommend
people check that out.
SETH PROCTOR: And so what's
really cool here, in case
people are missing this number,
is that we just went
in a few minutes from having
a cold environment to just
horizontally bringing hosts
online to get up above 1.6
million transactions a second
on what is a fairly
representative workload.
And that's cool on its own.
It's also really cool because
we're doing this on a virtual
public cloud environment.
And we've been able to hit these
kinds of numbers on our
own internal systems, but to
hit them on something like
Google Compute Engine
is just awesome.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
Say that number again.
TOMMY REILLY: We're up to 1.7,
if you look at the graph.
SETH PROCTOR: 1.7 million
transactions.
TOMMY REILLY: 1.7 million
transactions per second.
SETH PROCTOR: Per second, yeah,
which is, we think,
pretty respectable.
BRIAN DORSEY: So ending up at
this kind of number, what sort
of performance testing do you
guys do to evaluate the
environments?
Is it this sort of thing?
TOMMY REILLY: We use this
sort of thing, right?
So one of the things we look for
in a test like this is if
you start up eight nodes, you
look at the latencies, what's
the standard deviation?
Are the latencies nice?
It's good to have a
nice low average.
We're showing the average here
in this graph of under a
millisecond.
But are there any outliers,
that kind of thing.
So is node 32 really slow?
What's the full connectivity?
We use some off-the-shelf tools,
like Iperf, to measure
the bandwidth.
And you can measure
disk throughput
with some simple utilities.
We do stuff like that.
But generally, we're just
looking for nice, consistent
disk I/O and network I/O.
SETH PROCTOR: And part of the
reason we've created demos
like this is because
fundamentally, the
architecture of NuoDB is
radically different than most
relational database
architecture.
So it's very hard to just take
an off-the-shelf benchmark or
suite and say this tells us how
something performs in a
scale-out environment
like Google.
And so this is a fairly simple
demo we're showing, but it is
the kind of thing that we can
say, once we get those raw
numbers-- what does
the I/O look like?
What does the network
look like?
What does provisioning
time look like?
Then being able to take
something like this and say,
well, realistically,
can we hit--
we just hit 1.8 million
transactions a second.
So to us, this is
really exciting.
And this is really
how we do it.
So we have to take real
pragmatic applications and
say, well, can we make that
application or that
representative workload scale?
TOMMY REILLY: And
the application
didn't have to change.
This is off-the-shelf JDBC,
simple, using prepared
statements to execute
these queries.
You can see we're getting
sub-millisecond latency times.
If your application is just
simple JDBC and getting those
kind of times, you really don't
need it to add Memcached
to get the kind of low
latency you need.
BRIAN DORSEY: Just go directly
to the database.
TOMMY REILLY: The transaction
agents kind of replace that,
and your application is going to
remain simpler as a result.
SETH PROCTOR: Right.
That's a very important point.
NuoDB is, among other things,
its own caching architecture.
And so the transactions
are all running
on in-memory processes.
That's very powerful in
terms of failure.
That's very powerful in terms
of how easy it is to
provision new hosts.
But it also means that there's
no need-- and in fact, you
shouldn't be thinking about
adding additional caching
tiers or any kind of other
tiers on top of that to
optimize the system.
We're already taking care of
that for you, which is part of
the easy, out of the box
experience that we're trying
to provide.
BRIAN DORSEY: Totally.
And you touched on this
a little bit earlier.
But it seems like this was a
fair amount of effort to get
this up and running.
How did you find getting started
on Compute Engine?
SETH PROCTOR: It was easy.
TOMMY REILLY: Yeah, it
was fairly easy.
Linux is one of our main
supported environments.
We got up there, and it was
a nice, easy selection of
kernels to use.
We just could have picked
any one of them.
Deploying and installing
it was a breeze.
That was one of the things
covered in our blog.
The gcutil had a nice,
high-level layer of
abstraction for the things
we needed to do--
provisioning the disks, getting
the firewall set up.
All that was relatively
straightforward.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
Actually, can we show the
link to your blog?
TOMMY REILLY: Sure.
It's up there.
SETH PROCTOR: So this is a new
thing we've started doing in
the last few weeks.
We're trying to get our
engineers talking directly to
people who are interested
in the technology.
So this is meant to be a very
cut to the chase, pragmatic,
how you do things, how
the technology works.
We really encourage people to
go check it out, to give us
suggestions of what
they'd like to
learn about the product.
And then we're also going to be
collecting information more
specific to our Google Compute
Engine experience.
And as we generate more
benchmarks, as we generate
more experience there, we'll
be posting links there for
people to find it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
TOMMY REILLY: Our blog post on
Google Compute Engine was live
as of this morning.
So you can be the first person
to comment on it if you go
check it out.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
The live audience is the very
first people to see it.
SETH PROCTOR: Definitely.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
So you said before this is the
full relational SQL database.
But from what I understand, the
YCSB benchmark is really
more of a key value benchmark.
SETH PROCTOR: Yeah, so we've
got a little bit more time.
And we'll get Tommy to show
you one other thing here,
which is that we actually ported
JIRA to run on top of
our database.
And for those of you who haven't
seen JIRA, it's a very
popular, very powerful issue
tracking, project management
bug tracking system.
And so we actually run
it internally.
We run our JIRA instance
on NuoDB.
It was only a few
hundred lines of
code to get that going.
And most of that was just
writing the standard adapters
that they expect.
So it was really a pretty easy
out of the box experience.
And what we have here is
actually an instance running
on Google Compute Engine.
TOMMY REILLY: Yeah, so you
should see the results.
This is a frozen, older version
of the actual NuoDB
production bugbase.
So I can log in and see a
bug, reopen an issue,
and load and close.
And I'll assign that
to my boss.
And this will be saved.
And this is running on
the Google Cloud.
We took the snapshot, and
we just deployed it.
It was literally one
morning we got this
running, and it's done.
SETH PROCTOR: And if anyone's
used JIRA, anyone's had to
deploy JIRA, they know that
there's a lot of SQL that just
happened under the covers.
BRIAN DORSEY: To make
it all work.
So real database.
SETH PROCTOR: Real
database, yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: Any last
comments you guys
would like to make?
SETH PROCTOR: No, just this has
been an awesome experience
working with Google.
NuoDB is this really different
architecture.
It scales out.
It really take advantage
of compute resources.
It's really easy to work with,
but it needs something that,
in turn, is an easy,
provisionable environment.
And that's been our experience
at Google,
is that's just awesome.
So we look forward to continuing
to work on that,
and we'll be publishing
more as we go along.
And we encourage other people
to check it out.
It's great.
Go try NuoDB on Google
Compute Engine.
It'll be a good experience.
TOMMY REILLY: Yes, I can't
say that any better.
That was my thoughts exactly.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
So Seth and Tommy, thank
you both for coming in.
SETH PROCTOR: Great.
Thanks for having us here.
TOMMY REILLY: Thanks
for having us.
BRIAN DORSEY: Thanks
for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]